former crown prince hemza has said in a
newly released voice recording that he
would disobey orders by the army to not
communicate with the outside world after
he was put under house arrest
on sunday the jordanian government said
it distorted what it calls a malicious
plot to destabilize the country
the half-brother of king abdullah says
he's being punished for speaking out
against corruption
the situation is a little bit difficult
all the guards have left and the chief
of staff threatened me on behalf of top
agencies officials
where i recorded his words and sent them
to my family and those i know outside
the country
just in case something happened i'm now
waiting for their action
i'm not going to escalate but i will not
abide myself by their orders to stay at
home
not to use twitter not to be in contact
with people
and not to see my family what i've been
told by the chief of staff
is not acceptable under any
circumstances so i'm still waiting for
this matter to be sorted out well we
have natasha the name for us standing by
in amman to
talk us through the latest developments
natasha and tell us what this audio
recording suggests
what this audio recording suggests is
that what the government
on sunday described as a conflict a
familial conflict
that would be resolved between king
abdullah and his half-brother
prince hamza in a direct phone call is
morphing into
two camps and the division between two
camps
those who support king abdullah and the
opposition and those who support
what prince hamza is saying what you
hear in that phone call
is defiance a little bit of fear
and anger bear in mind that prince hamza
has been
echoing the frustrations of the
opposition here
talking about alleged widespread
corruption within the government
talking about malfeasance and what he
called incompetence by the government in
terms of
implementing what he believes are failed
economic policies
what you're hearing from the government
is that
prince hamza and his associates
conspired
with foreign entities to destabilize
jordan but we don't know
what foreign entities the government is
talking about as far as we know prince
hamza has not been charged with anything
and the government as of sunday was
maintaining that he has not been placed
under house arrest
arrest so again this recording at least
on the part of prince hamza
is a way to control the narrative share
his side of the story
and if there was any doubt already
prince hamza was extremely popular in
jordan
viewed as pious modest forging tight
relations
with the tribes and really echoing the
sentiments
of the opposition here these recordings
are only serving to make him
even more popular among a segment of the
population
natasha i wonder if you can just expand
a little bit on what you just touched on
and that is
some of the anger that some people feel
towards the government
which has been simmering in jordan for a
number of years why is that
absolutely the anger in jordan has been
simmering
since at least 2018 uh to be clear
jordan has a very difficult economy it
relies on foreign aid it has a
palestinian and syrian refugee
population
it has been dealing with the terms of an
international monetary fund about a 1.3
billion dollar loan that it's taken
and in 2018 the king was forced to
implement austerity measures that
included raising the sales tax
and the income tax and people here went
crazy they went to the streets and
protests for days they pushed out
the prime minister saying we are barely
scraping by and you're asking us
to pay more in taxes think of the
pandemic
think of covid19 basically as pouring
or throwing a grenade on the economy
which is already an inferno
the restrictions that have been
implemented by the government in an
attempt
to curb the pandemic have only served to
anger the public
so they're very upset about these
restrictions which they believe
are wiping out their livelihoods they're
very upset about what they believe is
widespread corruption
and so this is the backdrop so here
comes prince hamza
who is this is the first time at least
since king abdullah
has taken the throne where you're
hearing from a member of the royal
family
expressing a sort of simpatico
sentiments to the opposition
and critiquing the monarchy and what the
opposition is saying is that this
alleged plot
that prince hamza is being accused of
participating in
what it really is is part of a playbook
implemented by the government to crush
dissent even at the highest levels if
it's coming from within the royal family
analysts say that we do not expect they
do not expect that we will hear
further from king abdullah but as you're
seeing for a second day in a row we're
hearing plenty
from prince hamza yeah okay natasha
thank you so much for
that update from amman well earlier i
spoke to joey danani who's a former
deputy prime minister he's also the
former foreign minister of jordan
and he explained why the government is
not disclosing much information about
the situation
well i think i'm more inclined to
believe that his majesty
probably will look for an amicable
solution and
he will try to lay these fears of the
jordanian people
and their apprehensions at this
particular time
to to rest i believe that in the early
days of this
fury foray of events uh
there will be of course uh lots of
speculation
lots of guest making especially that the
information which is being supplied
when the whole case is under
investigation is being meager
and not sufficient to satisfy the
anguish
and the eagerness of people to know more
well i believe that at this particular
time this is
actually the question which is raising
the curiosity of
everybody if the whole situation has
been
being monitored then the only reason for
not revealing
sufficient information at this
particular juncture is because they want
to investigate more
and they don't want to spill more
information that may
frustrate the investigation because that
but but i believe that
in that some people probably may have
been
invoking and trying to destabilize
and move people to the streets to to
protect protest the
current unemployment and unikov 19
picking up and and so on and so
in a way there is some frustration and
emilio is encouraging for frustration so
they don't want